want to cut right to the chase which is
did the media force the administration's
hand on this matter no question about it
Tom it's extremely frustrating the White
House officials and it's actually
unnerving to some Defense Department and
intelligence community officials that
I've spoken to from the White House
perspective look you mentioned when did
this actually happen there's no firm
date on it but I'm told it's months not
weeks ago when this actually occurred
there were as they've stated there are
multiple other US hostages they believe
that are on the ground there there is
almost certainly planning for a second
operation or some type of follow-up
operation going on there is major
concern inside the administration and I
think vocalized concern that you've seen
in a lot of news reports from the
Defense Department that any operation
that they might be planning to go after
those remaining US hostages is now in
big trouble because of these news
reports when we look at the caliphate in
a Caliphate Without Borders does the
administration look at the Islamic state
is in Syria in Iraq or assault it is it
all one together geographically right
now they're not willing to grant that it
is actually a Caliphate or that it is
actually a state you'll notice Tom that
they only refer to it as ISIL they will
never call it the Islamic state that's a
little bit of they've just gotten used
to ISIL but it's also a rhetorical move
on their part they don't want to give it
that credit what's interesting about
this operation coming to light what's
interesting about the assumption within
the US intelligence community that the
execution of James Foley actually
occurred in Syria is up to this point
the 80-plus airstrikes that have
occurred they have been resigned to only
being in Iraq they have never expanded
to Syria now we know US troops have been
on the ground in Syria now we know a US
citizen has been murdered in Syria there
are a lot of calls from both parties to
expand those airstrikes to Syria that
pressure is going to continue to grow
Tom so I want to ask a question that
that may strike some as awkward or
uncomfortable and that is as Secretary
Kerry tries to work behind the scenes
has there been any discussion of ransoms
paid or anything like that Adam it's
really interesting you bring this up i
think there's the administration has
become frustrated and I think you've
heard from families of hostages that
have been frustrate
on the other side of this the US and the
UK are really the only two countries
that don't pay ransom now there's
negotiations that often occur but they
will not pay ransom what you've seen
with the Islamic state with you seen
with these militants in Syria is they've
made a lot of money over the last 12 to
16 months off European countries that do
pay for hostages the concern right now
within us within the US government is
basically the u.s. is working is faced
with the app the idea that European
hostages are being released because
people are paying ransom now the Islamic
state comes to the US and says well
obviously you're going to do the same
thing pay us money to continue to fund
our operations that's not US policy the
US says no and US hostages are in
infinitely more danger because of that
there's a really big problem I think
both on the countryside with the policy
but also these journalists the vast
majority of them are freelancers they
don't have large media organizations
that have either insurance policies or
the ability to go in and negotiate on
their own so these guys are really left
by themselves out there